okay uh this is my Star Wars Battlefront
video I've seen a lot of requests people
like hey when are you gonna play Star
Wars Battlefront have you gotten Star
Wars Battlefront what are you going to
review Star Wars Battlefront this is the
video Star Wars Battlefront that you
guys are getting and as you can tell by
the title it's not really a review of
Star Wars Battlefront I'm just informing
you all where I'm coming from as a gamer
and why I can't in good conscience get
Star Wars Battlefront by and large has
to do with the $50 DLC the Star Wars
Battlefront has to be clear from the
get-go this video is not meant to make
anybody who is enjoying Star Wars
Battlefront who bought Star Wars
Battlefront no like hey I loved it I
already got my season pass I'm having a
good time this video is not made for you
to feel like a piece of [ __ ] if you are
having fun with the game awesome power
to you game should be fun I'm glad
you're having fun this is just my own
personal principle and why I just can't
do it anymore
and didn't start with Star Wars
Battlefront this has been building
inside me like inside my gamer core for
quite some time in like mount st. helens
before it the pressure finally built it
exploded I was like I can't do this
anymore I can't play this game that
developers are playing with us the
gamers it started before star wars
battlefront it really liked when I drew
the line in the sand I was like I can't
do that anymore it was really with
destiny more specifically with the
taking King I had bought destiny but
then I ended up returning it because it
started to bore me no cigar whatever my
friends bought the season pass so they
got the expansions that came out smart
right well no because then the taking
king expansion came out they packaged it
with the core game the two expansions
that came before it and the Fallen Kings
would like alright now you're paying
full price for a game again so you paid
full price for destiny you paid for your
season past now you got to pay for
another entire game when really you're
getting 1/4 of a game it really made no
sense to me it was one of the things
where I always said if destiny ever
dropped down to like 20 bucks I'd
probably pick it up again and play it
but out of principle of that I can't
play destiny every 20 bucks one buck I
can't do it so enter star wars
battlefront star wars battlefront is a
full price $60 game that has $50 dlc it
is a $50 season pass that effectively
makes it a $110 game and EA had the
balls to buzz like you but there's no
microtransactions everything's cool
right no it doesn't matter because one
$50 transaction or
in five dollar transactions what's
better the fact is none are better it's
all $50 of crap you have to buy after
buying the game to get the experience
the game was crafted for so it really is
just robbery that everyone kind of
accepts and the gaming industry just
responds to your wallets they don't care
if you hate what they're doing they care
that you bought the games everyone is
bitching the [ __ ] $50 deal so you
still bought Star Wars Battlefront so EA
is smiling and they love you for it it
really reminds me of straight out of
Compton there's this scene where these
people are protesting NWA and have other
CDs and they're smashing them on the
ground and stepping on him I think it
was dr. Dre was looking at it it was
like [ __ ] him they already bought the
see it is it was such a great scene
because that is the point if you already
bought it you can scream as loud as you
want that you hate it but you already
bought it when the blu-ray releases of
the original Star Wars trilogy came out
like the first blu-ray release and Lucas
of course changed [ __ ] again Darth Vader
yelled nerd when you pick up the Emperor
and threw him off the thing I saw this
thing on TV and it was this group of
guys it review movies is what they did
and they were bitching about it they
were like oh this is [ __ ] I can't
believe he did that I can't believe you
change it again and one of the other
ones was like are you gonna buy the
blu-rays like well yes but [ __ ] you
George Lucas [ __ ] you for making me do
this and I remember seeing it I was like
you're buying it you have told him that
it's okay you've told them that it's
okay because you're going to buy it
anyway and that's just what companies
respond to is you speaking with your
wallet so on this on this principle I
just got to speak with my wallet on Star
Wars Battlefront a Star Wars fan one
[ __ ] Star Wars shirt Star Wars
Battlefront should have been the thing
that was like what fallout new Star Wars
man that's what I'm here for but I can't
again nothing against people who can and
who do if this is what you like awesome
have fun with it I just can't do it is
kind of like vegetarians I know this one
dude he's a vegan he's like I don't eat
animals because I don't like the animals
get killed for me to eat them but it's
nothing against people who do eat meat
it's just some people do some people
don't and this one I just I can't I'm
not naive and I'm not stupid I know that
EA is not gonna be like well Jeremy
didn't buy it [ __ ] we really got to
reevaluate this I'm not expecting a huge
change I would hope that people who
don't like it don't buy it
and so in that I mean if everyone who
hated the fact that battlefront had
$50.00 DLC didn't buy EA would genuinely
have to just really wait [ __ ] but um
maybe we shouldn't do that maybe we
should just release it in the game when
it comes out if I felt that the game
Star Wars Battlefront all-in-all would
be worth a hundred and ten bucks I'd
probably get it but I played it at PAX
and it was a pretty on par first-person
shooter with Star Wars skins and yeah
there's the argument like well if you
don't want to pay a hundred ten bucks
don't pay a hundred ten bucks you don't
need the extra stuff you can just pay
the sixty dollars for the game but you
can but really think about that because
I know I'm going to be playing it or
you'll be playing it someone will be
playing it they'll have the $60 game
they'll be like I'm only getting a $60
game I'm not paying the $50 DLC did one
of their friends will pay for the $50
DLC and it will admittedly have some
cool [ __ ] in there and they'll look at
it and they'll just see everything they
don't have and then they'll be like ah
well I want that so now I'm going to buy
it and that's just human nature and it's
also a human nature that companies like
EA count on they count on the fact that
the stubborn people who aren't going to
buy it are going to just buy the $60
game and you'll see they're friends with
the $50 DLC on top of it and then
they're just going to want the $50 DLC
because they want the cool [ __ ] that
they're seeing but it does make me feel
a bit
oh they're gamers now there are kids now
who game who don't know a world without
Dale say they don't know what it's like
to not get nickel and dimed after the
game was released Inc it's normal I am a
certain mindset among an environment and
the environments either going to destroy
me or the environments going to change
and I imagine I'm just going to get
destroyed but if enough people do this
and speak with their wallets then the
environment does have to change and
that's kind of my point of it that's my
video on Star Wars Battlefront that's
why on principle I can't get Star Wars
Battlefront because I can't just buy
something because it's Star Wars
so again if you're enjoying Star Wars
Battlefront you enjoy Star Wars
Battlefront but I myself I can't do the
DLC thing I've seen companies for long
enough treat DLC as the point of the
game being made there was a time where
DLC was kind of a byproduct of the game
to release like the game was released
now we can kind of tack on some extras
but now a core game comes out because
the DLCs were the money
and so it's kind of like it's all
reversed it's the dlcs the point and
that's where they make their money and
the games just kind of the byproduct of
how you get the deal see yeah I do want
to see what you guys say about it I do
read the comments believe it or not so
DLC what do you think about it is it is
it okay in among gaming or is it just
like you've had enough and it's just
[ __ ] whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
YY x XA b x a get the lightsaber in
minute one of the games slice through
some [ __ ]